[Music]
let's talk about looper you play uh
young bruce willis and so it's and and
it's fascinating because uh bruce willis
is your is you in the future you're the
younger bruce willis you're in scenes
together you are very convincing as a
younger version of bruce willis
character yeah very much so how did you
do that how did you capture the essence
of bruce willis i mean mostly just
hanging out with him that was the most
productive thing i did my homework and i
would watch his movies and stuff but
just hanging out with him he's such a
cool guy and we would you know have
dinner and talk about the movie or talk
not about the movie and you know when
you hang around with someone enough you
start to kind of
pick up little things yeah yeah what did
you notice about him because you're
you're doing some things that are very
bruce willis but they're not overt i
can't say i appreciate that i think uh
what did i know
there's one thing about him that i
noticed right off the bat um
that
he's such a powerful presence on screen
you'd assume that he would be loud
he's actually not loud he's very
soft-spoken yeah and but he's
he's got the confidence you know he
doesn't have to raise his voice but uh
and in a lot of his roles he doesn't
he's you know he's a quieter person
until he needs to yell and then he's
yelling but if he's just talking he
talks you know he talks down here like
this yeah yeah which so i i incorporated
that into the character but uh also
there were three hours of prosthetic
makeup so that helped
they lowered a bruce willis head on top
of you which you know at any point did
you ever say to him like how about
acting like me
i don't know what he would do though
yeah yeah
that's true
no no no you're acting like me now
uh we have a clip here from looper it
isn't the easiest movie to explain uh
quickly so i don't know what you can
tell us about this well it's a time
travel story and basically it's about
what you would say or do with your
future self if you ever got to meet them
um so in this clip this is the first
time that these two actually get to sit
down and have a conversation let's take
a look from looper
sounds down into your eyes
it's too strange your face looks
backwards
yeah so do you know what's gonna happen
you've done all this already as me i
don't want to talk about time travel
cause if we start talking about it then
we're gonna be here all day talking
about it making diagrams with straws we
both know how this has to go down i
can't let you walk away from this diner
alive this is my life now i earned it
you had yours already so why don't you
do what old men do
and die don't you just take your little
gun over between your legs and do it
boy
great really terrific movie